From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I'm Emily Crosby and we're here in the Hattiesburg Public Library with this Glenda Funches on December 2nd, 2015.
We're here with the Civil Rights History Project, which is a co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Also with us is John Bishop and Bill Husschenkar might be joining us later.
Thank you Miss Funches for the meal with us.
So, thank you. Welcome. Could you tell me when and where you were born?
I was born here in Hattiesburg, Mississippi on August 17, 1954, which I always say three months after the decision of Brown versus Blue to Education.
How long did it take you to realize that? How long did you get to be?
Well, I think I probably realized that after I got in college, there was exactly three months.
Can you tell us about your family?
Well, I come from a family of 12 children. My mother is originally from Alabama and my father is originally from Jefferson, Davis County, Mississippi, Prentice, Mississippi.
What did they do for a living?
My mother ended her working career working with the Department of Human Services. She was one of the first homemakers, which was like a social worker aid.
And my father, he was a chef at the University of Southern Mississippi. He liked to brag that he worked to about four or five presidents.
They gave him a reception when he retired.
Really? Yeah.
Was that was your mother doing that work when you were young?
Well, basically, she did my nursing sitting with ill people. She would do that.
She was ill people, yeah.
Where did you fall in the 12 children?
I am a little child. There are six under me, so number six.
So you must be used to having a lot of people with that on.
Actually, my oldest sister had finished high school. By the time I went into first grade, she moved to Cleveland.
They called them great migration, she moved up to Cleveland, Ohio.
So is she almost like an auntie or something for you?
Oh, well, she's like a second mother.
So where did you, or what were your community like, how did you broke down now?
Well, it's an opportunity to see a segregated community.
And there were black businesses that were thriving. We had cafes, cleaners, nightclubs, and we had hotels.
So I got a chance to see the separate society that basically African-American were subjected to in the 50s and 60s.
Were you aware of that as a political evidence?
Well, I think I became more aware at the freedom summer.
Because I was nine, going to summer, freedom summer.
And I knew we lived in separate society. We would see whites on the bus.
But I think the students with SNCC kind of opened their eyes that we had certain rights.
We were not exercising.
Like the public library or the one in public zoo. And those things like that.
What did you do for the school?
Well, I stored it actually in kindergarten with Miss Maddie Townsend kidding it.
And Miss Maddie Townsend was a civil rights activist.
Actually, she was one of the first female that there in Lignan who was the circular in the 60s registered to vote.
I went to her kindergarten up until the age of six and then I went to Mary Bethel Elementary School,
which was my neighborhood. And from there I went to Lily Gurney.
That was the year that we started to dismantle the school, dual school system.
Had a spot idea of what was called the stair step approach level.
And so in 65, 66, they'd be at grade one to four.
And then they added four more and 66, 67.
And then in 67, 68, the last four grades were added.
And that's how 12 grades were desegregated.
Was that desegregated with freedom of choice?
Freedom of choice. Compliance.
Yeah, you know, different, it was separate system.
You had to opt out going to the African American school.
And I was asked in 1967, 68 to go to Tim's junior high because it was somewhat a distant from the African American community.
And they did not have as many blacks at that school.
They were about four or five that went that first year and that would have been 66, 67.
So Miss Eurling Bowett who served on the education committee requested from my fingers that we be allowed my sister and I to go to Tim's.
Was that the education community with the NAACP?
At the NAACP she was.
And what did your parents say?
Well, they agreed.
I think what the NAACP was looking for students who had pretty good grades because they knew going into a hostile education environment that your grades had to be pretty good because you know, it was going to suffer some.
So my mother agreed.
I'm actually, my mother was working for a family.
The guy was paralyzed and she was just nursed.
And we went to say school is his son.
Now the wife had no problem with it but he, the man who was paralyzed, wanted to know what did the NAACP give her to send her kids to Tim's.
Would you know?
What did she say?
She told her nothing.
Nothing.
So my sister, Tim's was a junior high and also had an elementary school.
So his son was an elementary school.
And my sister, two years younger than me, she was an elementary school.
And I was in junior high.
So did they get an Iraq?
I don't think so.
No, she was in sixth grade and I think it was maybe about third.
So when they asked your parents and your mother agreed, did they talk to you all about whether you wanted to or did they just make the decision for you?
Well my next own neighbor, Gwen Bond, she had gone that first year to Hawkins.
And every day we would wait for Gwen to get off the bus and brief us on what happened.
So we were the opinion that Hawkins was where the poor wife's middle class and we would be going to tell us where the moral floing.
From freedom summer, we'd song off.
That the poor wife was with embrace integration.
So we felt like we might want to have the form the Gwen had, but we found out, hey, then you get reality.
Then you get reality.
So freedom summer led you to believe that you would have an easier time?
With the rich wife.
Was that because you associated the volunteers?
You know, they were middle class rich.
Kids coming south.
So you hear about the poor wife's and gravitating to us the clansmen and all that.
So we just knew that we were going to have that problem with the rich wife.
How did that work out for you?
It was a nightmare.
I would pitch myself to make sure I wasn't.
We were basically, it was a hostile school environment.
It went the whole day without anyone talking to us.
I think the menace grade of the principal is kind of set to tone.
And I think if he would have instructed the teachers to do these children coming into their environment,
make sure you make sure that they feel like they are poor at school.
So I was going nine months and no one eating with you.
I put my tray down and they would jump up.
And quite recently, five years ago, I received a letter from Delaware from a young lady who had gone to town.
So, you know, like lady who was a student back then.
And she was apologizing to me.
She recalled me putting my tray down and she jumping up.
My response to her, I sent her letter back accepting her apology.
But I don't recall who jumped up because it happened nine months ago.
So, you know, you have to know, you don't pay attention to people.
You just know you look up through that scenario, put your tray down.
Okay, big on-job.
But I think the teacher probably could have made it better if she would have came to herself.
Thanks for letting me eat with you today.
But that didn't happen.
Did the woman who wrote to the apology that she explained?
I mean, did she say why she was apologizing?
She said she was not a racist, but she was just in hell.
She was just not very enough to book the 8-gray system.
I mean, you know, I'm sure she would have suffered some type of re-progression if she would have done that.
So, she, you know, she tried to frame it.
You know, she did it because of her pressure, I guess.
Do you know what prompted her at that particular moment?
Well, we had done an article.
It was on Marlita Keenberg thing.
And Marlita Keen had visited my church two weeks before his death.
And I had given a civil rights marker in 1999.
I think the first one in the state, they had read a big article on that two-page article.
And she was home visiting her mother and she saw it.
So, she said she looked me up on the internet and sent my address.
The little one to my workplace, not to my home.
Her purpose, right?
And I invited her next time she come and we get together and maybe we have a lunch.
I haven't heard from her.
I don't know if she called on my home number or what, but I haven't heard from her.
What was it like in the classroom?
Well, in the classroom, like I said, from the first day, we were briefed by the principal.
We had any problem to report to Mr. Manguno, who was the assistant principal.
I was a little late getting into the class so I walked in and took a seat.
And immediately the science teacher told me, oh no, we don't let little girls and boys sit together.
So she moved me to a table in the front of the classroom on the right-hand side.
And there, I sat for the entire school, but I said, you know, it was a table with two chairs.
Right, right.
And was that true and where it wasn't only girls sitting with girls?
I think so.
Yeah, I probably was.
So you sat there by yourself the whole?
Yeah, and what did she finally get the nerve asked me, who I did that time?
I told her because I had to write.
So it's an incident, so I'll do that to semester.
I did this paper on Marlotte King because he, I was there when he spoke about the poor people march two weeks before his death.
He was here in Hansford on March 19th at Mountainside Church.
And so we had to do a history of paper.
That's okay, I love history.
But all the articles after his death and with the pamphlets that hit, I did it on Marlotte King.
So one day the history teacher said, I need to speak to you.
And outside of the clients, she said, some of the students got a whole year paper and they cut it up.
But you got to eat on it.
So it was what incident after another, you know?
Did you have much support?
Did you talk to other students who were going through different trades or schools?
Well, actually we rode a van to school.
My next door neighbor had a Volkswagen van.
And she picked up about, and asked me how 15, about 15 kids got on it.
It's an elementary school aged kids in junior high.
And so we were confirmed.
I guess she was out of therapists.
And really truly, they should have provided some type of counseling because, you know, Mr. Cippy had resisted integration.
You know, with the white citizen council and then the sovereign commission.
And I think that they dropped the bone in not providing counseling for us.
I was in court with a attorney from Hannesburg, up in Jeff Davis County, about two years ago.
And he was telling me about an incident that happened with a young man, an African-American guy, who was there during the time I was there.
And someone took their shoes, slapped him in the face with, and the coach said, well, we go to sit here until I find out who did this.
So he was interested in knowing where this young man was.
And actually we just found out two days ago that he got, he was living in Louisiana.
But it was all a type of incident that took place.
You know, I love core music.
And I took my core music.
And for some reason, Mr. Kelly, who was the core music teacher, always selected the third period class to sing.
And so we had to sing at the night grade class program.
It was like a commencement program for them.
And we were practicing on the song.
We had to, we had two days to memorize this song, to dream the impossible during.
And so I was sitting, this young lady started crying.
And everybody was wondering, why was she crying?
Here she said, my parents are coming.
And they're going to see me standing next to Glenda.
And for her, there was, very, she didn't want her parents to see her standing with the second soprano next to her.
So she was moved, somebody was moved.
We were not at the program.
We were not standing next to her.
Did you have a sense that she had trouble before that?
You know, you were there, did she miss her?
No, she didn't.
And I had core music.
You know, it was guys who would say, look, things like, will we sound a Negro spiritual?
I'm going to ride to chair you.
You want us to sing like, you know, the end word.
And so, you know, they used that quite frequently at times.
Was that unusual for a white core group to be singing in the other spiritual?
I think it was the teacher.
She was a lot, she missed Kelly, was real good.
So she, she, she in core, the reader too.
I don't know, but I'm going to ride to chair you in the morning Lord.
And then, then, bones, then, bones, then, dry bones.
Which, disconnect those bones, then, dry bones.
So, I had others, aren't usual, but did, she did.
Well, that's interesting.
So, I guess, the disheart, those that are parents with, she just,
Right, right.
She was a night grader, so she knew her parents was coming.
And I don't know what type of repercussion she was going to suffer as a result.
But, I guess she knew her parents better than I would.
But then, once, I guess, and Kelly always selected the third period.
I had a friend in the fourth period.
I know the African American.
We were only two eight graders, but schedules were identical to classes.
But, they put her in class by herself.
If I went to core music, third period, she went fourth period.
If I went home, I went to home economics.
Fifth period, she went sixth period.
But, they did put us in the same home room.
Twenty minutes a day.
So, that's the only time I got a chance to other than core music to kind of exercise my jaws.
We got together for that twenty minutes.
But, I had to go to a nursing home.
And so, I worried, how about, how am I going to get to this nursing home?
With the core music class.
And this lady had daughter's song, she was so nice.
That wrote with her.
And then, once we got to the performing, they said, walk around and shake.
Shake the people around.
And these people were born right after the Civil War.
They probably went, why is she here?
So, I had to go through that trauma.
Okay, do I walk around and shake her here when I know they really don't want to shake my hand?
It was one worry after no.
And did you continue?
That school, I left that school because it was quite obvious.
I would have stayed that my grade was going to drop.
And my next one, they even got her arm broke.
They made us every morning, the football player.
And we'd charge into it like we were on the football field.
A little girl.
And that's my story.
I don't know about the four people who went there the year before.
But they, so I transferred to the school on the other side of town.
The poor whites.
I want to know about your problem.
No.
And it had that problem because you had a good school administrator, Mr. Rogers.
And I was just amazed at that night grade that year I was a night grader.
And they had an African-American female to co-host with a white male.
And this young lady, this now, they call her the queen of talk.
Up in Detroit, at Erichel, I see a reminder of that.
We end up going to take some university together, but she is
real gigadises known as the queen of talk in the Detroit area.
But I was just amazed, but I think he set the tone that he was not going to.
So the leader should be a big deal.
And I think so.
I think it was all with the leadership, the Miniscreters.
When the first year or the second, or when you continued,
did you talk to your parents about it?
Did you eat at home?
Well, we would get calls.
I would get calls at home.
And I knew it was from when I was at Tim's with the affluent swipe.
I would get these telephone calls.
Oh man, I speak to Glenda Faye.
I see.
Nobody called me Glenda Faye, but there'd be a bit of a team of them.
I think we'll call them, they would make remarks and comments and stuff like that.
Did your parents talk to you about what you were going through?
Well, thanks a lot.
We talked on the bus and we talked to our younger siblings.
We educated them what we were going through.
We never let them forget what we were doing.
Well, my sister says she left after six years.
She told me, oh, it's nice to give her holiday.
Oh, we just celebrated the 50th anniversary.
We had a program that they were not going to use her as a giddy pig.
She went back to the African American School and then she stayed.
But I tried to hawk and then I went back to Rowean because I wanted to graduate from Rowean.
It was the African American High School.
So I went back after my ninth grade to African American School because that's where I was.
So you were like, okay, I've done one school or another school and now I'm going home.
I went back on one year.
I'm a freedom of choice back to the African American High School.
The second year that came out with another plan might 11th grade year called zoning.
So we had two high schools in the city.
We had hats for high school and then we had Rowean.
And so the white kids on the certain side of the railroad track had to come to Rowean.
But there were only five or six to kill.
And we had a program that two months ago, we recommend Dr. Nooncaster,
who was the president, William Kerry College, and then William Kerry University.
His son was the only white, two lily-burney junior high school.
And then there were a few at Rowean, maybe about five.
So we did a black history program.
And more of the keen program, we recognized two of them because actually they integrated the African American school.
Because lots of those kids had opt-out, opt-out, not to come to a white school.
But for them going into the African American school,
lots of them may not have gone to school.
I see my last year in high school, they came up with a third plan,
where they made the African American high school a all-ten grade.
And all the 11 to 12 graders went to high school.
So I was in the furthest, foolily integrated club.
So what's the, do you know what the racial makeup of the,
was it a county system or a city system?
A city, what city?
Do you know what the racial makeup was of the city at that time?
Like what the percentage?
Well, voting was, I do, but I think if someone like 30 or 40%,
about 35% African American.
Okay. And then when they finally consolidated the two systems,
did most whites stay or did they go?
They stayed the first year because it was kind of a surprise.
The court decision came down.
That summer.
But then the homes county came down like homes, the Alexander.
Yeah, I think it was a group of cases that went before.
And so the news came out that summer.
And so that's class in 1972.
I guess it was basically half and half.
And then they had set up this academy in 1965 called Beads of Academy.
I think it's B-E-E-S-O-E-N.
It was, they said it was the first year that they started
desegregating the Pannas Rapunzel School.
And you know, the first group of kids were elementary kids,
but then they started increasing as they increased the level of approach.
And so that was an option that some of them chose to go to your as opposed to.